I'm a female and I just pissed in a
bottle in a car
so it's 2017 hell yeah it is I saw my
friend a days video that he made a
little while ago he had some people sit
down and he gave them urination products
some females some females and I love
reading the comments cuz you guys are
hilarious I saw there's one comment that
made a lot of sense to me we did an
Amazon you know review of some urination
products but we didn't try it duh like
mind blown we want to give you guys what
you want so I'm gonna try a few of these
products alright right out here where
there is no toilet and site man let's
get to camping in peein that's all I got
to say so I have to go girl couldn't
find the guy to go poncho so actually
they're DIY I got to go poncho and
probably use that as a mail product to
have maybe one of my friends try it out
you know the same when you really got a
go in here in the car and they say to
pina cup well there's actually a product
that allows you to piss in the cup for
females and I think it's actually pretty
practical for those long road trips
where you can't make a stop so let's go
see I think this might be my favorite
product to try this weekend
go girl allows women the convenience of
standing to urinate it's clean portable
discreet and reusable now that's what I
call cool I don't know the design gives
me it makes me skeptical let's give this
a try guys honestly I'm gonna try to use
it through my pants since it says it's
out of convenience that we can stand
nice bathroom I'm just going to test all
of its theories my friends are right
over there and they don't even on pink
this is so awesome and I'm standing up
cos I'm standing up standing up for the
girls standing up but a girl oh so let
man every female should have a go girl
every female now
I'm really liking this not too much
splatter no man this go girl thing is
talk about convenience I'm a fan I want
you to try out this di oh I gotta go
poncho is basically a poncho that pers
that provides privacy for you to do your
thing all right yeah I'm down and I kept
moving into yeah yeah you could poop in
it put on the hood so I can get full
privacy all right I'm using the poop
poncho going for a poop right now and
it's pretty awkward just because I've
never really pooped outside like this
before it's super private I also think
it's private because it's pitch black
outside so no one can really see that
I'm pooping it's pretty cozy just going
for the poop
works well
I mean it is something you could use in
the woods but I feel like this is more
useful in cars I pulled over I'm at a
gas station right off of the highway
let's try it out shall we kinda has a
funnel so it looks like a Fitz mini
sheep and sizes push it up on there so
it's nice and tight I think I'm ready to
pee in a bottle I decided to sit in the
backseat of the car and do this you know
I feel like I get a little bit more
privacy the windows are tinted back here
I'm just gonna go for it feels like I'm
sitting on a mini toilet kinda sounds
like a toilet when it like goes down
into the bottle it sounds like it
flushes a little bit that's all I'm
gonna shake out pretty gross right but
I'm a female and I just pissed in a
bottle in a car so it's 2017 hell yeah
it is if you ever got to go in public
get one of these products you're good to
go yeah I completely love every single
product the go girl the mini toilet
didn't get to try to Pancho but I loved
it she loves watching me use the pond
yeah and as it was Eric looks like he
was really enjoying peeing in public is
no longer a problem in 2017 it's been
resolved not for ladies at least that's
been that's the name of this show it's
been resolved resolved resolved it
[Music]